okay welcome back everybody sorry for
the late start so we have exams back
today I published all of the grades on
line so you can see them on catalyst
with the means and the standard
deviations overall I think everyone did
exceedingly well so I'm very very
pleased with how everyone did I think
well more than half of the class got
like in the 90s which is great so the
the mean score is about a 91 so I'm
really pleased with how everyone's doing
I should also say that I don't have a
quota for like 3.0 and 4.0 so if I feel
like the class is doing well then the
average of the grades will be better
okay and I feel like everybody's doing
really well so far so thank you for
studying and paying attention and
learning this is great this makes it
more fun to teach when I think
everyone's actually learning okay so
today we're gonna do some fun things
we're going to do a kind of in-depth
example on the computer to study the
numerical integration of a complicated
nonlinear chaotic OTE okay all of the
fun things its chaotic its nonlinear and
we're gonna simulate it in the computer
today before I start I just want to do
two very very brief things so before I
wrote down what the order of accuracy of
the forward and backward Euler schemes
are and it's pretty simple to actually
derive that so for about two or three
minutes I'm just gonna derive you know
from scratch how accurate these methods
are so you can see how that's done and
then we're gonna cook up two more types
of numerical integrators the so-called
runge-kutta schemes which are like the
best integrators we're going to be using
in the class okay
so just very briefly we're gonna write
down the forward Euler scheme
okay so forward Euler the so the kind of
system that we're trying to simulate
looks like Y dot equals f of Y okay this
is just my ordinary differential
equation y could be a vector F could be
some nasty nonlinear vector valued
function okay kind of a general ordinary
differential equation and forward Euler
says that Y at time k plus 1 equals y at
time k plus delta T f of Y at K okay the
way we derived this expression was we
tried to use an approximate finite
difference derivative for y dot and then
when you plug that in you get this
approximate discrete time update for y
at future times based on Y at the
current time
okay forward Euler now
what we're going to do is we're going to
use the Taylor series of this function y
our solution vector and we're going to
see how close this Y at time k plus 1
approximates the true trajectory y at
time k plus 1 ok so what does this mean
we're saying y k plus 1 is really
approximating this true solution y at
the time TK plus delta T
okay so I'm going to assume that YK so
we're going to assume for the moment
that YK equals y of T k and so YK plus 1
is y at TK plus another delta T we're
stepping delta T in the forward every
time we advance this ok so our our
finite difference estimate YK plus 1 is
approximating this true solution so I'm
going to write this as like the true
solution ok now what can I do with an
expression like this to like expand it
out in powers of delta T I can take the
Taylor series and I'm going to expand
about the point TK so this is my base
point these are the powers I'm assuming
delta T is small so this is exactly
equal to Y evaluated at TK plus dy/dt
plus y dot evaluated at TK times delta T
plus y double dots at TK delta T squared
over 2 factorial plus I could keep going
down that top dot right Y triple prime
delta T cubed over 3 factorial and so on
and so forth okay so we're approximating
this true this true sequence here which
would be the actual solution if I
evaluated it at TK plus delta T okay so
there's a few simplifications we can
make right now that make our lives a
little simpler so first of all why at
time TK is just what I'm calling YK okay
what's y dot
F of Y all right that's my OTE so I can
say that this is F of Y evaluated at TK
so that's plus F of Y K delta T plus all
of this stuff I'm just gonna say that's
order delta T squared everything else
that I'm not gonna keep writing is just
order delta T squared and cubed and
forth and so on
so this is my approximation using
forward Euler and it equals my true
solution but it's off by a factor of
delta T squared okay so this is my
forward difference this is my forward
difference YK plus 1 and everything here
is error ok so that's how we derive that
for every little time step every little
Delta T time step of forward Euler we
pick up an additional delta T squared
error term okay are there any questions
about about how we kind of derive this
this error for forward Euler it should
be making sense at this point right we
know how to use Taylor series to
essentially evaluate like our
approximation and what the order of the
error term is so we know how this error
scales if we decrease or increase delta
T yeah good that's all I want to say
about that so now I told you that we
were we were essentially only looking at
forward and backward Euler because
they're simple enough that we can
actually understand everything about
them we can figure out what their error
properties are we can analyze their
stability on simple linear systems we
can really kind of understand everything
about them but in practice they have too
much error to really use so in practice
what we're going to do is use what are
called runge-kutta integration schemes
so once we see this notion of using a
Taylor series to think
about what the error is you could
imagine that there are other
combinations of YK and delta T and F
evaluated at different points that might
be able to cancel more and more terms of
this Taylor series and give you higher
and higher order schemes okay if this
was a numerical methods class I'd give
you an incredibly boring hour-long
lecture on Runge Kutta and deriving
these constants and I do this to my
undergrads and they hate it I should
stop doing it because I hate it too but
what I'm just gonna tell you are the two
most popular schemes that are built into
MATLAB and give you a little bit of
physical intuition about what they mean
okay so runge-kutta second-order and
when I say second-order I mean
second-order or globally and in MATLAB
this is the OD e 2 3 function so we've
been doing OD e 4 5 which is a little
bit better more accurate this is the
kind of baby version runge-kutta and so
what we're gonna have ok let's try not
to mess this up we're gonna have YK plus
1 equals y k plus
delta-t f maybe one more thing remember
we said we had y dot equals F of Y well
let's say that our right hand side our
vector field can also change in time
okay in my notes I have this the
opposite and this is gonna become a
problem so it's a function of time and
space so what are some examples of
vector fields or OD YZ that are the
variable in time and space sorry also
the spring should only the force should
only depend on your position if you had
a spring that like okay if you had a
rubber band so some of you will probably
remember that if you had a rubber band
you know it's super stretchy but if you
leave it in a drawer for ten years it
gets really brittle so that would be
something that over a very long period
of time the spring constants actually do
change the example I always think of is
fluid flow that's probably my bias so
let's say I'm in the Gulf of Mexico I'm
from here so this fluid flow depends on
the local Sun load and the weather and
the winds and it not only is a function
of space Y but it's also a function of
what time in the day you're actually
dropping this buoy in the ocean or
spilling oil doing whatever you're doing
okay so what we have is an update okay
and so what we're going to do I really
don't want to mess this up and I'm
pretty sure I'm going to so let me just
look at my own notes
so I was just about to tell you that you
should remember this no matter what this
is so important and I totally forgot the
formula okay so we're going to evaluate
our function at time TK plus delta T
over two and at a point YK plus delta T
over two at times F evaluated at T k YK
seems like a weird expression maybe a
little bit complicated but it's actually
really easy to interpret what's going on
here okay so the way that I like to
think about this is that I break this up
into two steps first I say let's call
this F 1 ok so I take my vector field
I shouldn't have erased it so I take my
vector field and I evaluate it at my
current point of time and space so right
now I am here ok I evaluate my vector
field at the current point in time and
space and I think okay well I'm pointing
this way ok so then what I do is I take
a little 1/2 forward euler step so I
move half a DT forward in time and I
move a half forward Euler's step forward
in space so not a full Euler step this
is a half Euler step right delta T over
2 so I move this little half Euler step
forward in time and then I see what's my
vector field look like there what's the
vector pointing if I took a half boiler
step forward in time well here my vector
might be pointing a slightly different
direction and now I'm going to use that
new vector direction which I'm going to
call f2 and I'm going to take a full
Euler step in that direction I'm going
to say this again because this is a
little hard to digest and I'm just
saying inwards so you can derive this
expression from scratch if you have
essentially you have some
of these constants and where you
evaluate your vector field you could
actually derive this algorithm from
scratch to have second-order accuracy
and I'm not going to do that so what
we're doing here instead of just taking
a forward Euler step so what that means
is at this point I evaluate my vector
field F and I would take a full delta T
step forward
all right that's will get me here that
would be order delta T squared accurate
locally so instead what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take a half oiler step
in that direction and I'm going to query
my vector field and say what's my vector
field at that new 1/2 wheeler step
forward and I'm going to use that
modified vector Direction f2 and I'm
going to take a full Euler step in that
f2 direction not in the original f1
direction for some reason you can kind
of work out the math and it's a huge
mess this is more accurate this is plus
order delta T cubed locally in space all
right start in time and what that means
is that for every time step I'm picking
up a delta T cubed error term which
means that my global accuracy is order
delta T squared okay so this is global
order delta T squared okay so I should
probably stop and let people ask
questions about this because this is
kind of a detailed expression it might
not even be clear exactly what we're
evaluating here
so f is a function of time and space
so we're evaluating this F at this time
and at this spatial vector we got this
spatial vector by taking 1/2 forward
Euler step and then using this F
evaluated at this new 1/2 Euler stepped
position we take a full oil or step in
that direction yeah you just have a
vector of data your data points your
delta T apart how do you evaluate okay
so if I have a vector of data then that
so there's a fundamental difference
between integrating a vector of data to
find the area under the curve and
integrating a trajectory in some
differential equation so I'm assuming
that I have some function f that I can
evaluate at any T and why I like that's
a really good point so I'm assuming that
if you want to know what the velocity is
at any point you name I can tell you
what that velocity is and that's not
always a great assumption because you're
actually getting these points on a
discrete grid so I think you're making a
really good point like these velocity
field measurements probably come from
some satellite data on a grid and so I
might have to do interpolation between
the data that I have to evaluate F at
you know intermediate values of Y where
I might not have exact data points okay
so maybe this makes sense does it it
probably doesn't make sense how you
would actually code this up in MATLAB
though like how many of you feel like
you could code this up right now
it's okay how many of you don't
necessarily okay so we're going to do
this for another example that's a little
bit more complicated so let me just
write this out so that's what we're
gonna do for the whole second half of
the classes we're going to code up these
fancier better runge-kutta integrators
and we're gonna try them out on a neat
example vector field okay
so the next better runge-kutta is our k4
and this is the eau de 45 algorithm in
MATLAB okay so now we're gonna do a
fourth order global runge-kutta and i'm
just going to write down what the answer
is and then we're going to code it up
okay so we have y at time k plus 1 is
equal to YK plus I'm going to add up
four terms that I'm gonna have to
evaluate separately so delta T over six
times something called F 1 plus 2 F 2
plus 2 F 3 plus F 4 okay so f1 is just
my function evaluated at TK and YK I
just measure my vector field I plug in
you know time k YK what is the vector
direction at the point I'm currently at
at the F 1 F 2 is the vector Direction
1/2 forward Euler step farther along so
that's F of TK plus delta T over 2 and
YK plus delta T over 2 F 1 so literally
if I have some right-hand side function
f I can plug in T k YK and I get F 1
it's a vector then I can plug in you
know 1/2 time step later and YK plus
delta T over 2 times
vector f1 and I can evaluate my new
vector field at that point so this is my
this is what vector direction it's
pointing 1/2 Euler step in the future ok
F 3 is f of basically the same thing 1/2
euler step in the future but pointing in
the f2 direction the way we can think of
this is that we're getting a more and
more refined estimate of what the local
velocity field looks like not just at my
point but at nearby points and then
we're going to take some kind of an
average of all of those local nearby
velocity fields and we're gonna see the
best direction to take a full step in
and finally f4 is a full Euler step TK
plus delta-t YK plus delta T f3 yep okay
so it's not I haven't explained to you
why we're doing these why we have a
delta T over 6 plus all times all of
these F sand and why we're evaluating
these intermediate points but at least
now this is something that we could code
up in MATLAB ok if I have some right
hand side function f that takes in a
time and a spatial vector I can evaluate
it to get f1 then I can plug that in to
get f2 and then I plug that in to get f3
and in to get f4 and now I have these
four vectors and I can add up this
expression to get y at time k plus 1 ok
so we could at least code this up ok are
there questions about kind of the
geometric meaning of like why we're
taking these half steps and what we're
doing
right the idea is again if I was doing a
naive forward Euler then I would take my
local direction of my vector field F F
at T KY K this is F 1 and I would just
go blindly and take a full delta T step
in that direction that's forward Euler
okay so I take a big Delta T step in
that direction that's forward Euler but
really we know that the vector field is
actually not pointing in that direction
forever so what I do is I take 1/2 delta
T step and I notice that now my vector
fields pointing in a different direction
and so I use that direction and I say
okay maybe I'll take a half oiler step
in that direction and now my vector
field is pointing in this direction so
I'm going to take a full Euler step in
that direction and now I'm going to take
an average of all of these final points
that I've queried all of these F 1 F 2 F
3 and F 4 vectors all of these
directions I'm going to take some
weighted average of these directions
because I've queried for different
points in my flow and I'm gonna take a
full Euler step in that direction and
I'm gonna get much much closer to the
true answer because some special
property of this combination cancels out
lots and lots of powers of delta T and
the Taylor series expansions I would not
recommend trying to prove that this is
plus order delta T to the fifth it's
kind of a nightmare it'll give you a new
respect for runga and Kutta but we can
kind of take it for granted as far as
I'm concerned we can abstract this away
the things that matter is that I have to
adieu for function evaluations so this F
might be expensive
this might mean running a fluid
simulation that takes five hours ok so
running four of these might be really
expensive ok so this takes four function
evaluations which is more than forward
Euler four times more than
forward Euler but it's order Delta T to
the fifth local accuracy which means
it's globally order Delta T to the
fourth so this is so much more accurate
that we're willing to pay the extra
price of four vector field evaluations
to get that delta T to the fourth
accuracy yeah I'm sorry
export it doesn't have a half step yeah
so you take a half step for f2 and you
take a half step for f3 but then f4 you
take a full step in the f3 vector
direction don't ask me why like it's
part of the canceling all these terms in
the Taylor series it's you have freedom
over there's actually a whole family of
fourth order runge-kutta type
integrators so there are other
combinations of taking you could take
like a two thirds to third step and then
a full step or a one-third two-third
full step there's a whole family of
possible integrators and basically what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
in a principled way sample the local
vector field to get a better idea of you
know what the curvatures and third
derivatives and fourth derivatives are
so that you can cancel them all out and
take a big step and get pretty close to
the right answer so there's lots and
lots of linear combinations of similar F
ones and f 2 years and f 3s an F force
this is the most famous one it probably
has some special properties that I don't
know about because everyone seems to use
it okay so this is OD 45 in MATLAB yeah
is one is the runge-kutta family over
so I'm calling these steps half forward
Euler steps because that's exactly what
they look like to me but really you
could take like okay I think I know what
you're saying so the the runge-kutta
schemes are fully explicit meaning that
you're always evaluating something then
plugging it in then evaluating something
then plugging it in and then evaluating
something so you're never having to back
solve some implicit function like you
wouldn't a in the backward Euler scheme
yeah there are other high order schemes
that are implicit and as a general rule
implicit scheme schemes are more stable
but they're much harder to solve you
might could have a stable solution but
right these ways are specifically chosen
to cancel out the order delta T squared
delta T cubed and Delta T to the fourth
terms and if you change any of these
weights or any of these half steps if
you don't change it in exactly the right
way you're gonna pick up error terms
that are much much larger than delta T
to the fifth so these are like very
specially finely tuned so we call this
tuning your integrator this is a
highly-tuned integrator I can't imagine
how much time that must have taken them
to come up with this tuning maybe they
just tried a bunch of things and it
worked then enough sometimes that
happens yeah give it sink kind of
accuracy solution as like the fourth
with a really small delta T which except
for picked out a lot of the vector error
yeah so if you wanted an equivalent
forward Euler scheme you'd have to have
a delta T that was you know like if I if
I ran a runge-kutta with time step point
one I'd have to run this I'd have to run
my forward Euler with the time step
point oh oh oh one yeah so so there you
could get that accuracy if you had a
really really small time step with
forward Euler but remember we always
have numerical roundoff precision in our
numbers and so there's a fundamental
limit to how good forward Euler
and get and this can get smaller errors
it's a general rule let's here delta T
is getting smaller when we do that half
step but it's that so so this is our
delta T we're gonna take we're going to
move delta T 4 in the future and I can
do it in a very accurate way with 4
function evaluations I have to evaluate
those functions at intermediate times
and space and things like that but we're
really counting how many function
evaluations okay so this is for function
evaluations where as forward Euler is
one function evaluation but if I had to
decrease my DT to 0.0001 for forward
Euler that's 10,000 more time steps so
I'm still doing 2500 times better in
terms of accuracy in terms of efficiency
for the same accuracy and if I wanted to
be more accurate it just gets worse and
worse and worse like it'll be 2500
squared times worse ok let's let's keep
moving on so we're gonna code this up
for a neat differential equation so one
of the earlier demonstrations of
numerical chaos so I told you last time
that Poincare a proved that the
three-body problem was chaotic and that
there is no closed-form solution for the
general motion of three planetary bodies
in 1963 Ed Lorentz wrote down the
Lorentz equation to study atmospheric
like turbulence and thermal transport
essentially this is an atmospheric
convection model and so he wrote down
this is Lorentz
and he wrote down this very simple
three-dimensional OTE okay so we had X
dot y dot Z dot equals so X dot is just
Sigma times y minus X Sigma is a
constant so this is linear the X term
the X equation is just linear the Y dot
equation is x times Rho minus Z minus y
okay Rho is also a constant so now we
picked up a simple simple non-linearity
minus x times Z and then the Z dot
equation is x times y minus beta Z so
here's another non-linearity x times y
okay and he found that for certain
constants Sigma Rho and data
so Sigma 10 these are the famous
constants you can find him on Wikipedia
8/3 and Rho equals 28 for these
constants and for many other constants
you get extremely interesting chaotic
behavior so how many of you have heard
of the like Lorenz attractor okay or the
butterfly effect so the butterfly effect
is I think what is more commonly known
as because it looks like butterfly wings
all that stuff about a butterfly causing
a hurricane is ridiculous so the the
Lorenz attractor is this funny butterfly
looking thing and the property of note
to us a very very interesting property
is that the system is chaotic and what
that means is that if I start with two
extremely nearby points they might agree
for a little while except very quickly
their behavior does completely different
things
so very quickly no matter how close you
start these two points to each other
after some very short amount of time
they're going to do very different
things they're going to just go to
different you know phases of this
butterfly attractor and have different
behaviors so we're going to code up this
system we're going to try it out in
runge-kutta
with our runge-kutta scheming we're
gonna see what happens okay any
questions about the Lorenz attractor or
equations before we so fundamentally
this structure of the system of
equations is what's causing the chaos
and you are changing the weighting of
the non linear nonlinear terms versus
the linear terms by eight by changing
beta and Rho and Sigma so if you make
you know beta and Sigma and Rho larger
you're making the linear term seem
stronger and if you make them smaller
than you make the nonlinear term seem
larger and as a general rule bigger
nonlinear terms are more chaotic but
that's not always true okay so a few
things we're gonna do first we're gonna
cook up a Lorentz equation we're gonna
say function DUI equals Lorentz of T
comma y comma Sigma Beta Rho all of
these codes are online so you can
download them and they're also in the
lecture notes
so we're basically creating a function
that gives me the right-hand side of y
dot equals F of Y okay my Lorentz
equation we were we're writing this
function called Lorentz and it's going
to return a three vector of all of these
right-hand sides because that's what OD
45 watts it wants the right-hand side of
my OD
okay and that's what I need for my Runge
Kutta scheme right I need the F of T
comma K comma Y I need all of these I
need to be able to evaluate this
function f on the right hand side that's
what Lorentz is okay and then we have Y
is a three dimensional state vector and
dy is a three vector with Sigma times y2
minus y1
so this why in MATLAB is a big three
vector and it contains x y and z okay so
y2 is y y1 is x + y3 is z sorry for the
it's kind of a bad naming convention but
I'm going to stick with it okay then the
second equation what's my second
right-hand side equation okay X times
Rho minus Z minus y okay and then my
third equation x times y minus beta
times okay that's my right-hand side
this will return a three vector of you
know X dot y dot Z dot let's call this
Lorentz okay good we have our right hand
side vector so now we can evaluate f1 f2
f3 and f4 right because we have F of T
comma Y that's our Lorentz function does
that make sense right you have we have y
dot equals F of T comma Y this is the
function Lorentz and now we're going to
use this Lorentz function to get f1 f2
f3 and f4 and to take our runge-kutta
step okay so now i'm going to make
another function called function y out
equals RK for single step so we're gonna
write our own version of OD 45 we've we
know what the function for a runge-kutta
step is so I'm gonna write a code that
just does that step okay it takes the
runge-kutta fourth-order time step and
this is a function of some function i
have to give it a right hand side
function i have to give it a dt i have
to give it an initial time and an
initial position or if you like this is
like TK and YK okay okay so f1 equals
what is f1 equal
okay it equals my function which is
going to end up being Lorentz it's gonna
equal my function evaluate it at TK
comma Y K that's F 1 so f 1 equals fun
of TK y K super simple right and you're
gonna be able to plug in your function
that you find interesting like for this
lecture we're gonna do Lorentz but this
is a totally general runge-kutta
integrator you're going to be able to
define any function or any right hand
side and you're gonna be able to
integrate that right hand side okay
anything that you pull UGG into fun
you're gonna integrate okay what about
f2 f2 is fun of what this is a lot of
fun what's F 2 TK plus DT over 2 and
then 1y k plus DT over 2 times f1 all
right okay f3 TK plus DT over 2 YK plus
DT over 2 times F 2 F 4 is function TK
plus DT YK plus TT x f3 done okay last
step I've just computed all of my F's
but I haven't computed my next actual
state vector y at time k plus 1 so my Y
out this is like YK plus 1 is YK plus DT
over 6 times F 1 plus 2 F 2 plus 2 F 3
plus F 4 so all we just did is code up
that fourth order runge-kutta integrator
that we had written on the board and
that means we have to evaluate our
vector field at these different points
in time and space our vector field is
this function our right hand side vector
field
okay questions about this code
okay good we're moving along we have a
Lorentz vector field we have a function
that integrates vector fields and now we
need to write a loop to essentially
start with some initial condition and
walk it forward okay so this is the last
step so we're gonna clear all clothes
all CLC and we're going to enter in
Lawrence's parameters these are the
classic chaotic versions
okay so Sigma equals 10 beta equals 8/3
and Rho equals 28 and we're going to
pick some initial condition like Y
naught y naught equals minus 8 827 I
tried a lot of these different initial
conditions a couple years ago and I like
this one okay and now we're going to
compute our trajectory okay so we need a
DT right we're stepping this initial
condition we're going to go from y 0 to
y 1 to y 2 to y 3 and so on we're going
to build up a trajectory and we get to
pick what the DT is between each of
those little steps how big or how little
of a step do I take okay so I'm going to
choose a small step to begin with 0.01
and I'm going to make a time span equals
0 to DT to 4 so we're gonna go from time
0 to time for in increments of DT and
what I'm going to do is just like we did
in the previous example every time I
step forward my state I'm just gonna
tack it into a big matrix that contains
all of my state histories okay so I'm
going to say this big matrix of history
the first column is why not okay and
then I'm gonna say YK equals y naught
for I equals 1 to time span whoo what is
happening here
okay for one equals timespan and divided
by DT sorry I'm just gonna run this real
quick okay so my time span is this big
vector of time and so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to iterate for every
single element in my vector in my column
vector of time I'm going to take a step
forward okay so for I equals 1 to time
spans and divided by DT maybe for one
equals length time span I'm going to say
okay time equals I times DT and YK plus
1 equals so YK plus 1 is going to equal
my Runge Kutta of YK so this equals RK
for single step of my function at T
comma Y Lorentz G comma Y comma Sigma
beta Rho DT time YK ok this is really
complicated and it's gone off the screen
so my function RK for single step I have
to give it a function to integrate and
the function I'm going to integrate is
the Lorentz equation and I'm going to
lock in Sigma Beta Rho and turn this
into just a function of T comma Y
because our our K for single step
integrator that we wrote just takes in a
function of T comma Y there's no other
parameters ok so we have a function to
integrate this is just like what we
would do in ode45
we would make this function a function
of T comma Y by locking in Sigma Beta
and Rho and the other things our rk4
single step took it took it wants to
know what is the DT what is the current
time and what is the current state YK
this is how we wrote it right like we
wrote this code to have these four
arguments okay so I'm gonna save that
and now I'm going to tack in my new YK
plus as a new column in my history of
all of my states so now the the history
this big capital lie is my old history
plus this new term YK plus 1 and now YK
equals YK plus 1 ok this is a lot of
steps to build an integrator ok we have
to count through all of our time that we
want to evaluate for every DT for every
DT we plug in YK into our integrator and
we get YK plus 1 and we add that to our
histories that we can keep track of it
and then at the end of every single time
step my new YK becomes my old YK plus 1
right the YK plus 1 from the last time
step becomes YK for the new time step
okay so that's our integrator I really
hope I didn't make a mistake cuz I don't
have time to fix it let's just see if
this runs good it runs there are
probably no mistakes so now we get to do
some cool things like plot 3 and we're
gonna plot our history this Big Y matrix
so if I type size of Big Y it's a three
by 402 matrix okay so it has three rows
and 402 columns so for x y and z i have
those states at 402 points of time so I
can plot the first row versus the second
row versus the third row using this plot
three command and I'll see what the
actual trajectory of XY and Z does in
space
okay and this is my Lorentz trajectory
you could have just plugged this into
ode45
okay full disclosure we could have used
woody 45 but I want us to be like you
know there's no mystery around ODU
forty-five there's a very concrete set
of steps they were chosen specifically
to cancel error in a particular way and
when you write a for loop you can take
some Y naught and get y1 and y2 and y3
and you can step through and get this
full trajectory for the floret system
okay last thing I'm going to do before
questions is I'm just going to do the
same thing in ODU 45 and plaudits so OD
45 also takes in a function of T comma Y
and I have to give it my time span and
my y naught and then I can plot the same
thing in red if it's not good okay and
our solution agrees pretty well with OD
45 so you will notice though that
towards the end of the trajectory we're
actually starting to disagree okay so
even very very subtle differences in how
we implement this algorithm for a
chaotic system can cause the
trajectories to eventually begin to
diverge so we'll talk more about that on
Friday before before we close so on
Friday we're going to go more into depth
on Runge Kutta integrators we're gonna
look more at the chaotic nature of this
system looking at other trajectories and
error and things like that but before we
do that I want to go through and just
see if there's any questions about this
code for the last couple minutes
okay we defined a right-hand side vector
field some fun some function that's
Lorentz we have some function
runge-kutta for single step which if you
give me YK and the vector field and the
current time and DT I can tell you the
next YK plus 1 using the 4th order Runge
Kutta scheme then we have a for loop so
if we're gonna you know we count through
for every DT I take my state YK and I
get YK plus 1 and then I start over
again I do the same thing over and over
and over again so this is how you build
an integrator ok it's a for loop
wrapping around a single step where you
evaluate you know some vector field and
take little steps forward ok we're gonna
go a lot more into depth we're gonna
look at how to do this quickly yeah
maybe they do find the size of the
matrix capital i I do so I'm this is a
terribly abusive MATLAB thing you can do
where I am dynamically making Y bigger
and bigger and bigger
I never told MATLAB what size why is
this is bad code because every time I'm
having to copy this into a new Y so this
is actually slow I'll show you more
about that later ok